the US government has announced new
immigration restrictions on six
countries citing security concerns the
Department of Homeland Security will
suspend visas that can lead to permanent
residency for nationals from Eritrea
Kyrgyzstan Myanmar and and Nigeria Sudan
and Tanzania will also stop receiving
receiving diversity pleasers that award
green cards to countries with low
immigration numbers to the United States
travel restrictions have been in place
on Muslim majority countries that is
Iran Libya Somalia Syria and Yemen since
2017 Gabriel Elizondo with more now on
the honan
security announcement from Washington
well administration officials are saying
that in their words it's not a travel
ban they're saying it's just travel
restrictions it only applies in theory
at least they say to a certain group of
people that want to come to the United
States it would be citizens of these six
countries but they say it would only
apply to immigrant visas for people that
from those countries that want it to
move to the United States administration
officials are quick to point out that it
will not apply they say to people that
are applying for student visas or work
visas they also say it will not affect
any of the citizens currently in the
United States from these six countries
that are legally here on valid visas
they're saying it simply will only
affect those that are applying for new
visas to immigrate to the United States
but that still potentially is a lot of
people thousands of people potentially
any people from these six countries that
will be applying from here on out for
immigrant visas to the United States
with a few exceptions we'll have those
visas denied now administration
officials are saying they're trying to
avoid the situation of 2017 and that
so-called a Muslim ban on those seven
come predominantly Muslim countries
worried they were coming to the United
States at airports being detained held
sent back to their countries it's on all
sorts of confusion and heartache for
many families the Department of
Department of Homeland Security is
saying they're specifically trying to
avoid that by making this a little bit
more clear however the big question is
when this goes into effect which is
February 22nd
how will it actually play out at
airports in reality and that's a big
question that will have to wait and see